Adam McKay who I admire greatly and  who's one of the funniest humans alive  we had a meeting we're sitting there  talking he said how would you like to  how would you like to do a feature film  in four days and I went I liked that  idea and then he said how would you like  to play Donald Trump and I loved that  idea I didn't care if I knew if I was  capable or not I wanted to try so yeah  so I I did my bit is Donald Trump you  don't want to be Donald Trump because  he's the way he speaks is very specific  yeah  were you telling all the Mexicans to get  off set I told them to build me that  wall  I want a sensational wall fabulous wall  I don't remember what the question was  but doesn't matter because I'm not gonna  answer it anyway  I walk over at this point I write oh god  maybe he won't remember me would be  humiliated was it to pee in can't do any  form of bathroom like the guys who made  it we're like when she's a girl she  doesn't go to the bathroom so I standing  up